today I wanted to well this morning I
want to talk about the future of human
driven transportation about how we can
cut congestion pollution and parking by
getting more people into fewer cars and
how we can do it with the technology
that's in our pockets and yes I'm
talking about smartphones not
self-driving cars but to get started
we've got to go back over a hundred
years because it turns out there was an
uber way before uber and if it had
survived the future of Transportation
would probably already be here so let me
introduce you to the jitney in 1914 it
was created or invented by guy named LP
Draper he was a car salesman from LA and
he had an idea well he was cruising
around downtown Los Angeles my hometown
he saw Rawlings with long lines of
people trying to get to where they
wanted to go he said well why don't I
just put a sign on my car that takes
people wherever they want to go for a
jitney that was slang for a nickel and
so people jumped on board and not just
in Los Angeles but across the country
and within one year by 1915 there were
50,000 rides per day in Seattle 45,000
rides per day in Kansas and a hundred
and fifty thousand rides per day in Los
Angeles to give you some perspective
uber in Los Angeles is doing a hundred
and fifty seven thousand rides per day
today a hundred years later
and so these are the trolley guys the
existing transportation monopoly at the
time they were clearly not happy about
the jitney juggernaut and so they got to
work and they went to cities across the
country and got regulations put in place
to slow down the growth of the jitney
and there are all kinds of regulations
there were licenses often they are
pricey in some cities fewer jitney
driver you were required to be in the
jitney for 16 hours a day in other
cities they required to jitney drivers
for one jitney but there was a really
interesting regulation which was they
had to put a back seat light install it
in every Jimmy to stop a new pernicious
innovation which they called spooning
okay
all right so what happened well within a
year this thing had taken off but the
jitney by 1919 was regulated completely
out of existence that's unfortunate
because well when you can't share a car
well then you have to own one and car
ownership skyrocketed and it's no wonder
by 2007 there is a car for every man
woman and child in the United States and
that phenomenon had gone global in China
by 2011 there are more car sales
happening in China than in the US now
that all this private ownership of
course had a public cost in the u.s. we
spend 7 billion hours a year wasted
sitting in traffic 160 billion dollars
in lost productivity of course also
sitting in traffic and 1/5 of all of our
carbon footprint is spewed out in the
air by those cars that we're sitting in
now that's only 4% of our problem though
because if you have to own a car
then that means 96 percent of the time
your car is sitting idle and so up to
30% of our land in our space is you
storing these hunks of Steel we even
have skyscrapers built for car
that's the world we live in today now
cities have been dealing with this
problem for decades
it's called mass transit and even in a
city like New York City one of the most
densely populated in the world and one
of the most sophisticated mass transit
systems in the world there are still 2.5
million cars that go over those bridges
every day why is that well it's because
mass transit hasn't yet figured out how
to get to everybody's doorstep and so
back in San Francisco where I live the
situation's much worse in fact much
worse around the world and so the
beginning of uber in 2010 was well we
just wanted to push a button and get a
ride we didn't have any grand ambitions
but it just turned out that lots of
people wanted to push a button and get a
ride and ultimately what we started to
see was a lot of duplicate rides we saw
a lot of people pushing the same button
at the same time going essentially the
same place and so we started thinking
about well how do we make those two
trips and turn them into one because if
we did that ride would be a lot cheaper
up to 50% cheaper and of course for the
city you got a lot more people in a lot
fewer cars and so the big question for
us was would it work could you have a
cheaper ride cheap enough that people
would be willing to share it and the
answer fortunately is a resounding yes
in San Francisco before uber pool we had
well everybody would take their car
wherever they they wanted and the bright
colors is where we have the most cars
and once we introduced doober pool well
you see there's not as many bright
colors more people getting around the
city in fewer cars taking cars off the
road it looks like uber pool is working
and so we roll it out in Los Angeles
eight months ago and since then we've
taken 7.9 million miles off
the roads and we've taken 1.4 thousand
metric tons of co2 out of the air but
the part that I'm really but my favorite
statistic remember I'm from LA I spent
years of my life sitting behind the
wheel going how do we fix this my
favorite part is that eight months later
we have added a hundred thousand new
people that are carpooling every week
now in China
everything super-sized and so we're
doing 15 million uberpool trips per
month that's 500,000 per day and of
course we're seeing that exponential
growth happen fact we're seeing in LA -
and when I talk to my team we don't talk
about hey well 100,000 user 100,000
people carpooling every every week and
we're done how do we get that to a
million and in China well that could be
several million and so uber pool is a
very great solution for urban carpooling
but what about the suburbs this is the
street where I grew up in Los Angeles
actually a suburb called Northridge
California and well look those those
mailboxes they kind of just go on
forever and every morning at about the
same time cars roll out of their
driveway most of them one person in the
car and they go to work they go to their
place of work so a question for us is
well how do we turn all of these
commuter cars and literally there's tens
of millions of them how we turn all
these commuter cars into shared cars
well we have something for this that we
recently launched called uber commute
you get up in the morning get ready for
work get your coffee go to your car and
you light up the ubirr app and all of a
sudden you become an uber driver and
we'll match you up with one of your
neighbors on your way to work and it's a
really great thing there's just one
hitch
it's called regulation so 54 cents a
mile what is that well that is what the
US government has determined that the
cost of owning a car is per mile you can
pick up anybody in the United States and
take them wherever they want to go at a
moment's notice for 54 cents a mile or
less but if you charge 60 cents a mile
you're a criminal
but what if for 60 cents a mile we could
get half a million more people
carpooling in Los Angeles and what if at
60 cents a mile we could get 50 million
people carpooling in the United States
if we could it's obviously something we
should do and so it goes back to the
lesson of the jitney is by 1915 this
thing was taking off imagine without
regular without the regulations that
happened if that thing could just keep
going would our how would our cities be
different today would we have parks in
the place of parking lots well we lost
that chance but technology has given us
another opportunity now I'm as excited
as anybody else about self-driving cars
but do we have to really wait 5 10 or
even 20 years to make our new cities a
reality with the technology in our
pockets today and a little smart
regulation we can turn every car into a
shared car and we can reclaim our cities
starting today thank
Travis thank you thank you you know I
mean the company we've built is
absolutely astounding you only just
talked about a small part of it here a
powerful part the idea of turning cars
into public transport like that it's
cool but a couple of the questions that
I know they're out there on people's
minds so first of all last week I think
it was you know I switched on my phone
and tried to book an uber night I
couldn't find the app you had this very
radical very bold brave redesign sure
how did it go did you notice other
people also not finding the app that day
are you going to win people over for
this redesign well first I should
probably just say well what were we
trying to accomplish I think if you know
a little bit about our history it makes
a lot more sense which is when we first
got started it was just black cars it
was literally you push a button and get
an s-class and so what we did was almost
what I would call an immature version of
a luxury brand that looked like a badge
on a luxury car and as we've gone
worldwide and gone from s classes to
auto rickshaws in India it became
something that was important for us to
go to be more accessible to be more
hyperlocal to be about the cities we
were in and that's what you see with the
patterns and colors and to be more
iconic because a you doesn't mean
anything in Sanskrit and the you doesn't
mean anything in Mandarin and so that
was a little bit about what it's about
now when you first roll out something
like that I mean your hands are sweating
you've got you know you're a little
worried what we saw is a lot of people
actually at the beginning we saw a lot
more people opening the app because they
were curious what they would find when
they opened it and our numbers were
slightly up from what we expected okay
that's cool now so you yourself as
something of an enigma I would say your
supporters and investors who have been
with you the whole way believe that the
only chance of sort of taking on the
powerful entrenched interests of taxi
industry and so forth is to have someone
who is a fierce relentless
competitor which is certainly proved to
be some people feel you've almost took
in that culture too far and you know
like a year or two ago there was a huge
controversy where a lot of women got
upset how how did it feel like inside
the company during that period did you
notice the loss of business did you
learn anything from that well look I
think I've been an entrepreneur since
I've been in high school and you have in
various different ways you're going to
you know an entrepreneur will see hard
times and for us it was about a year and
a half ago and for us it was hard times
too
now inside we felt like you know I guess
at the end of the day we felt like we
were good people doing good work but on
the outside that was an evident and so
there was a lot that we had to do to
sort of you know we've gone from a very
small company I mean if you go literally
two and a half years ago our company was
400 people and today it's 6500 and so
when you go through that growth you have
to sort of cement your cultural values
and talk about them all of the time and
make sure that people are constantly
checking to say are we good people doing
good work and if you check those boxes
the next part of that is making sure
you're telling your story and I think we
learned a lot of lessons but I think at
the end of it we came out stronger but
it was it was certainly a difficult
period I mean it seems to me every way
you turn you're facing people who
occasionally you know give you a hard
time
some uber drivers in New York and
elsewhere mad as hell now because you
change the fees and they can barely
declare and barely afford the deal
anymore
how you know you said that you started
this originally just the coolness of
pressing a button and summoning a ride
these things taken off you're affecting
hope the whole global economy basically
at this point you're being forced to be
whether you want it or not a kind of
global visionary who's changing the
world I mean dude who are you do you
want that are you are you are you ready
to go with that and B what that takes
well there's there's a few things packed
in that
question so first first first is on on
the pricing so I mean keep in mind right
mubarak's when we first started was
literally ten or fifteen percent cheaper
than our black car product it's now in
many cities half the price of a taxi and
we have all the data to show that the
drivers are making more per hour than
they would as taxi drivers what happens
is when the price goes down people are
more likely to take uber at different
times of the day than they otherwise
would have and they're more likely using
in places they wouldn't have before and
what that means for a driver is wherever
he or she drops somebody off they're
much more likely to get to pick up and
get back in and so what that means is
more trips per hour more minutes of the
hour where they're productive and
actually earnings come up and we have
cities where we've done literally five
or six price cuts and have seen those
price cuts go up over time so even in
New York we have a blog post we call for
September's compare the earnings
September after September after
September same month every year and we
see the earnings going up over time as
as the price comes down and there's a
perfect price point you can't go down
forever and in those places where we
bring the price down but we don't see
those earnings pop we bring the prices
back up so that addresses that first
part and then the enigma and all of this
I mean the kind of entrepreneur I am is
one that gets really excited about
solving hard problems and the way I like
to describe it is it's kind of like a
math professor you know if a math
professor doesn't have hard problems to
solve that's a really sad math professor
and so at uber we like the hard problems
and we like getting excited about those
and solving them but we don't just want
any math problem we want the hardest
ones that we can possibly find and we
want the one that if you solve it
there's a little bit of a WOW factor in
a couple years times say five years time
I don't know when you roll out your
incredible self-driving cars but
probably a lower cost
then you currently pay for an uber ride
what do you say to your army of a
million drivers plus at that time it
explained that again at which time at
the time when you when self-driving cars
a culture sure it looks like they don't
take over yeah what do you say to your
drive well look I think the first part
is it's going to take it's likely going
to take a lot longer than I think some
of the hype or media might expect that's
part one part two is it's going to also
take there's going to be a long
transition these cars will work in
certain places and not in others for us
it's an interesting challenge right
because well Google's been investing in
this since 2007 Tesla is going to be
doing it Apple is going to be doing it
the manufacturers are going to be doing
it this is a world that's going to exist
in the for good reason a million people
die a year in cars and we already looked
at the billions or even trillions of
hours worldwide that people are spending
sitting in them driving frustrated
anxious and think about the quality of
life that improves when you when you
give people their time back and it's not
so anxiety-ridden so I think there's a
lot of good and so the way we think
about it is that it's a challenge but
one for optimistic leadership where
instead of resisting the resisting
technology maybe like the taxi industry
or the trolley industry we have to
embrace it or be a part of the future
but how do we optimistically lead
through it are there ways to partner
with cities are there ways to have
education systems vocational training
etc for that transition period it will
take a lot longer than I think we all
expect especially that transition period
but it is a world that's going to exist
and it is going to be a better world
Travis what you're building is
absolutely incredible and I'm hugely
grateful to you for coming to Ted and
sharing so opening thank you so much
very much
you